- WHAT UP, HOMIES?
- WELCOME TO...
both: CUNNILINGUS CLASS.
- I'M SHABOOTS MICHAELS.
- I'M T-RAY TOMBSTONE.
- AND WE'RE HERE TO TEACH Y'ALL
HOW TO...
both:
GO DOWN ON BITCHES RIGHT.
- NOW BITCHES AIN'T BEING
SATISFIED, SO CHECK IT.
- QUIT SUCKING
ON THAT [bleep] SO DAMN HARD.
- BITCHES DON'T LIKE
THAT NONSENSE.
- THAT'S LIKE PUTTING THE TIP
OF YOUR PENIS
IN THE VACUUM.
- Y'ALL NEED TO...
both: CHILL ON THE [bleep].
- GO AROUND THAT BUSINESS.
- THAT'S LIKE A BUTTON
MADE OF A MILLION PENIS TOPS.
- NOW EVERY BITCH
LIKE HER CUNNILINGUS
A LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT.
- VAGINAS ARE LIKE SNOWFLAKES.
- SNOWFLAKES IS DIFFERENT.
LEARN YOUR BITCH'S SNOWFLAKE.
- ASK YOUR BITCH
WHAT SHE WANTS.
both: THEN DO WHAT SHE SAYS.
- SOME BITCHES LIKE IT
IN CIRCLES.
- SOME BITCHES
LIKE IT UP AND DOWN.
- SOME BITCHES LIKE IT HARD.
- SOME BITCHES LIKE IT SOFT.
both: COMMUNICATE
WITH YOUR BITCHES.
- MAKE THE ALPHABET
WITH YOUR TONGUE.
- A-B-C-D...
- AND WHEN SHE GRAB YOUR HAIR
LIKE SHE GONNA PULL
YOUR DAMN HEAD OFF...
both: STAY WITH THAT LETTER.
- I'M TALKING ABOUT B...
[blathers]
- OR D...
both: VAGINAS DESERVE RESPECT.
- YOU DON'T WANT SOMEONE
SLAPPING AROUND
YOUR LITTLE HOMEY.
[yelping]
- YOU WITH THE HAT.
- YO.
- HOW YOU LIKE YOUR BJs?
- DAMN, DOG,
ALL THE TIME.
- SHUT THE [bleep] UP!
THAT'S 'CAUSE PENISES IS EASY,
AND VAGINAS IS HARD.
THEY'RE...
both: CONFUSING!
- IMAGINE THERE'S AN EXPLOSION
AT THE ENVELOPE FACTORY.
- FLAPS EVERYWHERE.
A WORLD OF FLAPS.
- AND YOU NEED TO LICK YOUR WAY
OUT THE FACTORY.
- BUT EVERY BITCH'S FLAPS
IS DIFFERENT.
- LEARN YOUR BITCH'S
PARTICULAR FLAPS.
- FLAPS BE...
both: CRAZY!
- EVERY FLAP
NEED TO BE LISTENED TO.
- AND THEN YOU WILL GET OUT
OF THAT FACTORY ALIVE.
- STAY DOWN THERE.
both: PLAN YOUR BREATHING
LIKE YOUR SWIMMING.
- YOU GOTTA BE TALKING ABOUT...
both: STROKE, STROKE, BREATHE.
STROKE, STROKE, BREATHE.
[gasping]
- ALL RIGHT.
LET'S TAKE A FIVE-MINUTE BREAK.
- AND WHEN WE COME BACK,
WE GONNA TALK
ABOUT WARMING YOUR BITCHES UP
BEFORE YOU GET BUSY.
- AND HOW TO LAST
FOR MORE THAN TWO DAMN MINUTES.
- TAKE A PEACH AND PRACTICE.
- PRACTICE ON A PEACH.
- WELL, I THINK
IT'S GONNA WORK.
- 30 DOWN,
3 BILLION TO GO.
[maniacal laughter]